[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Welcome
to The Boardwalk at I/O.
This space really captures
the festival vibe,
and it's one thing
that makes I/O special.
This year, we collaborated
with a bunch of artists
to combine our tech
with their talents.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This interactive
easel takes my doodles
and makes them
museum-quality works of art.
So what I've drawn here is
obviously "Starry Night."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SHOUTING]
That's my job.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This art installation is
called "Mosaic Virus."
It uses machine
learning to create
flowers, whose
appearance is based
on the fluctuation of Bitcoin.
They're pretty nice.
I kind of want some of
these in my backyard.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm here with Kenric
and Alex, and they
curated all of the awesome works
of art here on The Boardwalk.
Kenric, please tell us about
them, and how you curated them.
KENRIC MCDOWELL:
Well, we've been
working with
artists for a while,
and particularly in the work I
do, working with artists that
use artificial intelligence
and machine learning,
and so we wanted to highlight
some collaborative projects
by artists working with
machine learning that provide
representation of
natural phenomenon,
like onformative's piece
here, "Meandering River,"
or an Anna Ridler's "Mosaic
Virus," with the tulips.
So we really wanted people
to see images of themselves,
in collaboration with nature,
through machine learning.
EMILY FORTUNA: Very cool.
And you alluded to this, Kenric.
This is an ongoing
collaboration, not just
happening at I/O. Alex, can
tell us a little bit more
about the history behind that?
ALEX CZETWERTYNSKI: Yeah,
so for the last two years--
this is the third year that
we've been doing an arts
program at I/O. And
every year it grows,
and it feels great
to see how there's
support for this
kind of presentation
at an event like this.
And I think that
this year, we're
changing the format
a little bit,
and we're seeing how
essentially bringing
the artwork on a place
like The Boardwalk
is allowing a deeper
interaction with them.
And I think the audience
is really responding really
well to this kind of work,
like onformative's piece.
EMILY FORTUNA: Alex
and Kenric, thank
you so much for sharing,
and making this happen.
It's really a lovely
place to hang out.
ALEX CZETWERTYNSKI: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Hey, guys.